حسنًا، لم يكن الأمر رائعًا بالنسبة لما
كان عليه الأمر، بل بالنسبة للمكان الذي حدث فيه، حيث
أقامت مجموعة صغيرة من المسؤولين الإسرائيليين الزائرين، بما في ذلك وزير الاتصالات الإسرائيلي،
صلاة للاحتفال بعيد السكوت اليهودي،
لكن هذا حدث في الرياض بالمملكة
العربية السعودية وتحت إشراف المملكة العربية السعودية.  القانون الإسلام
هو الدين الوحيد الذي يمكن
ممارسته علنًا في المملكة،
لا سيما على الرغم من أن القادة الإسرائيليين والسعوديين
يعملون على تطبيع
العلاقات. ينضم إلينا الآن ستيفن كوك،
زميل كبير لدراسات الشرق الأوسط في
مجلس العلاقات الخارجية، من
الجيد رؤيتك مرة أخرى
من الرائع أن أكون معكم، حسنًا، كان هذا النوع من
اللحظات مذهلة في حد
ذاته صلاة بمناسبة
عيد العرش اليهودي الذي يقام في المملكة العربية السعودية
في الرياض أم، ومن الواضح أن كلا
الجانبين يرسلان رسالة هنا لأن
هذه الصور تم نشرها للعامة  إذن ما هي
الرسالة، نعم، إنها شيء غير
عادي إلى حد ما ولم أعتقد مطلقًا
أنني سأراه في حياتي في
صلاة يهودية تحدث في الرياض ويتم
بثها للعالم. أعتقد أنها
إشارة أخرى من السعوديين
إلى أنهم مهتمون بالتطبيع.
العلاقات مع إسرائيل والأهم
تطبيع اليهودية في
مجتمعهم لم يمض وقت طويل حتى
أشارت مصادر الإعلام السعودي الرسمية إلى
اليهود على أنهم أحفاد الخنازير والقردة
لذلك أه يشير إلى تغيير كبير أه
في اتجاه وجهة نظر السعودية
وليس إسرائيل فقط  لكن اليهودية
كدين، أريدكم أن تستمعوا إلى
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين ياهو وهو
يتحدث الشهر الماضي في الجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة.
لا شك أن
اتفاقيات إبراهيم بشرت ببزوغ فجر عصر جديد
من
السلام، لكنني
أعتقد أننا على أعتاب
اختراق أكثر دراماتيكية هو سلام تاريخي بين
إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية، لذا فإن
التحدي الأكبر الذي يواجه
اتفاق السلام هو أن يأتي من داخل
حكومة فاري الائتلافية برئاسة نتنياهو وأولئك الأعضاء الذين
يعارضون تقديم تنازلات
للفلسطينيين نعم بالتأكيد أه ذلك
في الواقع، المشكلة هي أن السعوديين
كانوا واضحين جدًا أن الأمر ليس مسألة
إذا، بل سؤال متى، لكن
نتنياهو لديه مشكلة داخل
ائتلافه حيث أن لديه أه
مجموعة متنوعة من الأعضاء اليمينيين المتطرفين في
ائتلافه الحاكم الذين  ولو
سألتهم هل يفضلون
التطبيع مع السعودية أو
ضم الضفة وتغيير
وضع المقدسات في
القدس القديمة سيختارون
الضم في تغيير وضع
المقدسات أه حتى يحسم
ذلك  مشكلة سياسية، أعتقد أن
السعوديين سيتخذون الخطوات التي
رأيناها دون أن يكون هناك نوع
من الاتفاق الكبير الذي
ألمح إليه رئيس الوزراء نيتو في
الأمم المتحدة والذي تم طرحه أيضًا في المزيج هنا
قبل خمس سنوات، جمال كوساكي، الكاتب في
مجلة  واشنطن بوست قُتل معارض سعودي بناءً
على أوامر من
ولي العهد السعودي، لذا، ما مدى أهمية هذه
الصفقة الدبلوماسية مع
إسرائيل في هذا التواصل مع إسرائيل، كما تعلمون
رغبة المملكة في تحسين
العلاقات التي توترت بسبب هذا
القرار بسبب ذلك الأساس  قتل
كوساكي وأنت تعلم محاولة تحسين
تعرف صورتها إذا
أردت نعم أعتقد بطريقة غير مباشرة
هي أه أعتقد أن بث هذه
الصلاة الزيارات العامة جدًا
لوزيرين إسرائيليين على التوالي أه هي
مجهود  ليثبت للكونغرس الأمريكي
على وجه الخصوص أن هناك فوائد
للتطبيع ولأن إسرائيل لا تزال تتمتع
بشعبية كبيرة أه بين أعضاء الكونجرس فإن
هذا سوف يرتد لصالح
السعوديين، إنه ليس رهانًا سيئًا
للسعوديين ولكن هناك بعض
أعضاء الكونجرس أه السعوديون يبقون في
ما وراء الشحوب حسنًا كما
يبدو على المرشد الأعلى الإيراني
تحذيرًا من أن أي دولة إسلامية
تفكر في تطبيع العلاقات مع
إسرائيل تستشهد بالموقف النهائي
للجمهورية الإسلامية وهو أن
الحكومات التي تعطي الأولوية
للمقامرة  التطبيع مع نظام د سيتكبد
خسائر حيث يقول الأوروبيون
إنهم يراهنون على حصان خاسر ثم
تنبأ بتدمير إسرائيل
أه لكن هل كل هذا
معقد بعض الشيء بالنسبة لإيران التي
أعادت مؤخرا علاقات مثل د مع
نظام د
السعوديين نعم المرشد الأعلى كان أه
نشطا بشكل خاص على تويتر اليوم
بتهديداته أه لإسرائيل
وتحذيراته لتلك الدول التي
ستطبع العلاقات مع إسرائيل أعتقد
أنه يوحي بأن الإيرانيين
متوترون جدا من أه هذا التطبيع
ولكن ليس التطبيع فقط  مع
إسرائيل ولكن حزمة دفاعية رئيسية قد
تكون جزءًا من أي اتفاق تطبيع
بين إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية
ستأتي مع حزمة دفاعية بين
الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية.
يرغب الإيرانيون في إخراج
الولايات المتحدة من منطقة الخليج دفاعيًا.
الحزمة تعني أن الولايات المتحدة
موجودة هناك على أساس أكثر استدامة، St
دائمًا سعيد جدًا معنا، شكرًا
لك، من الرائع أن أكون معك